that's another strong quarter from you
guys who continue to gain subscribers at
the expense of Verizon at the expense of
AT&T hang your tents your tweet
yikes AT&T terrible q3 results could
explain the focus on buying another
company any other diversion tactics what
do you really think about the AT&T Time
Warner deal well Emily you know must
have been a great quarter for t-mobile
because I'm getting to interview with
you as opposed to lately you've moved on
to Kings and movie stars and you know
small CEOs like me about left in the
lurch so thank you for having me I can
tell that's a great sign this quarter
for us was fantastic 2 million net
additional customers and interestingly
that's 14 quarters in a row over a
million and an average of 1.9 and we
always talk about postpaid we had a
million eight hundred and fifty one
thousand postpaid phones
fascinatingly 684 thousand prepaid
phones with record ARPU of $38 in one
cent and something we don't talk too
much about in the wireless industry we
had revenue growth and service revenue
growth of 13% and adjusted EBIT our
growth of eight thirty eight percent
that's something inherent in these
results that you don't see low churn
service revenue growth winning on both
sides and yes you know a lot of this has
come because ever since AT&T bought
DirecTV in 2014 they have not gained a
single postpaid customer and they've
been the biggest contributor to our
success so I can only say in the short
term this distraction with them trying
to take over the entertainment industry
is going to be a boom for the you know
for the short-term future of t-mobile's
growth but what about the long term sure
you are gaining subscribers but your
competitors are making moves that they
believe put themselves in a better
position for the future a more powerful
position a more diversified position you
know what happens over the longer term
when you're just a carrier
okay well again what's important emily
is if you even AT&T announced earnings
today Verizon announced earnings last
week they are diversifying because the
business that they're in is shrinking so
and and we're the reason that's
shrinking we have a sustainable growth
business in the wireless industry
Verizon and AT&T need to create new
revenue streams each new one is falling
off you versus falling Wireless is
falling now when you move more to the
strategic concept of how do you take the
seventy million customers that we have
with these mobile devices and provide
them access to all of the content that
they want to view I don't see the need
to own and control the content the way
AT&T is already with binge on in with
t-mobile one we have an ability for our
customers to view on a mobile basis and
there are so many ways that I can
innovate to be an aggregator of content
and a search and discover capability on
content by others and a big big part of
this deal with AT&T and Time Warner will
be them ensuring the government that
they're not going to close down
optionality for everybody else on the
content that they have certainly I would
hope